herman un chantier pédagogique qui est
créative qui est vraiment notre notre
fer de lance pour l'année c'est celui de
la motivation scolaire donc l'année
passée on a travaillé comme nouveauté
d'apprentissage professionnel pour ci
dessous donne une compréhension commune
du conseil de la motivation scolaire
nous poursuivons notre et à bourg
puisqu'on est ce parce que ça puisse
descendre dans les classes tout près de
nos élèves et que ça puisse avoir un
impact sur la réussite scolaire
le deuxième enjeu c'est de poursuivre la
promotion et le rayonnement d'école dans
la communauté avec comme objectif puisse
dire est l'ultime d'augmenter nos
clientèles scolaires
on a travaillé dans le passé on a subi
dans le passé une baisse démographique
et ce alors occasionné toute une
réflexion dans l'école sur qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire justement pour ramener
notre clientèle à un niveau optimal
un beau petit mâle qui vont favoriser
les meilleurs services dans l'école
donc on avait atteint un creux de vague
et l'on est en augmentation clients à
atteindre sont tous extrêmement
stimulant mais faut poursuivre les
travaux pour ramener ça à un niveau
d'apd plairont 150-200 et dieu merci